hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
today we are venturing back into the
wonderful world of voice-acting showing
you the people behind some of your
favorite characters in all the latest
and greatest video games if you ever
hear a voice in a game and think where
have I heard that before well this is
the series for you I'm particularly
excited for today's episode as we're
going to be taking a closer look at the
voice cast of Final Fantasy 7 remake one
of the most anticipated games of 2020
[Music]
where else could we start other than
Final Fantasy sevens blond-haired
blue-eyed protagonist Cloud Strife well
hell no we're not starting there the
real star of this game is Tifa Lockheart
Knight
this time around t fur will be played by
Britt Barron an actress who broke into
the industry a few years ago I was just
happy to be there with everyone and be a
part of something that I believe in and
a show that I'm proud of mainly known
for her TV roles and shows like Lucifer
and Grey's Anatomy before now being a
huge part in the Netflix hit show about
the gorgeous ladies of wrestling ogle oh
four shots so far she's appeared
alongside actors like Alison Brie and
Marc Maron in all 30 episodes of filmed
to date which is pretty damn good going
while she has been busy landing a badass
suplex or two over the last few years
that hasn't made her a stranger to the
world of gaming her voice has popped up
in halo 5 guardians Dishonored 2 and can
most recently be heard as the voice of
ADA 1 in destiny to what we offer
Guardian is privileged dammit that's
impressive it's gonna be a huge year for
both Britt Barron and Tifa Lockheart
Tifa
so okay we should have started with the
main character of the game Cloud Strife
so let's do that now
our hero of the piece is voiced by
American actor Cody Christian who has
spent most of his acting career in
various TV shows and movies do you
recognize his voice this is a one-time
gig when it's done we're done
so really it's like hey hi nice to meet
you I'm Cody and then it's hi nice to
meet you I'm cloud no not interested
despite being just 24 years old you may
have already seen him pop up in a bunch
of different projects including films
like kill the Irishman and the starving
games a Hunger Games parody movie that
well wasn't great in my humble opinion
but maybe it was your movie of the year
no the starving games aside he has also
shared an entire scene with acting
juggernaut Bruce Willis in the film
surrogates and I add he was only 14
years old at this point
imagine that being 14 and acting with
Daddy die heart
Cody has plenty of TV experience too
including a decent stint on the popular
Teen Wolf TV show and remember that one
for later it's going to pop up a strange
amount of times if you got something
else in mind I'm okay with that too
oh and here's a curious fact about our
Cody Final Fantasy 7 remake won't just
be his first video game it'll be his
first ever voice acting role of any kind
considering cloud is the character at
the heart of Final Fantasy 7 story
Cody has some damn big boots to fill on
the other side of the spectrum is the
antagonist of the piece
this is Sephiroth the one winged angel
is voiced by Tyler hoechlin run away
you have to leave you have to leave I
feel like I didn't want to have any kind
of temptation to emulate or imitate
anything that someone else has done so
who much like Cody Christian started
taking on roles in Hollywood at a very
young age appearing opposite actors like
Tom Hanks and Daniel Craig in the
oscar-winning movie road to perdition
when he was just 15 years old
[Music]
Tyler soon found himself getting regular
TV work with his biggest role coming in
drumroll please
Teen Wolf see I told you it was gonna
come up again his role in the show
lasted a lot longer than his in-game
rivals appearing in an impressive 63
episodes
across six years while Tyler might also
be new to the world of video games he's
no stranger to stepping into the role of
an iconic character recently Tyler was
able to Don the Cape of the Man of Steel
himself appearing as Superman in various
DC comic book shows including the flash
arrow and legends of tomorrow when they
all came together for a crisis of
Infinite Earths story arc see if the
bullets don't work right why the
punching pretty impressive
fortunately [ __ ] allowed he won't have
to take on Sephiroth alone our
protagonist will have a band of allies
around him on this journey in the form
of Avalanche as expected our old friend
Barret Wallace will be leading from the
front and he'll be voiced by John Eric
Bentley nothing worth fighting for was
ever won without sacrifice I am John
Eric Bentley the voice actor for
finalsub Fantasy 7 remake for Barry jon
is a veteran of film and TV and he's
been working flat out since the
mid-1990s which is actually before
clouds voice actor was even born but not
before me I feel old
in recent years he's managed to secure
roles in such huge Hollywood
blockbusters including Transformers
Revenge of the Fallen and even the
greatest film ever made Resident Evil
extinction
Who am I kidding that is not a great
film anyway his video game work is just
as impressive he can be heard in some of
the biggest games of the last decade
including Red Dead Redemption - The Last
of Us and gran
theft auto 5 and believe me that's only
scratching the surface mr. Bentley is in
a metric ton of video games oh and
Marvel fans may also recognize John as
the voice of Nick Fury he's voiced the
Avengers head honcho for years in video
games including Lego Marvel superheroes
and last year's Marvel Ultimate Alliance
3 the black order that's a long-ass name
for a video game if we want to survive
this we do it as a team luckily the rest
of the gang are all well accounted for
two bigs will be wisecracking his way
through the story under the watchful eye
of Gideon Emery still he's a
professional unlike the rest of us I'm
glad to have him I was I was saying
earlier to somebody that liked a role
that excites me as a role whether you
know the writing is good easily the most
prolific actor in this list Gideon has
been credited with over 200 different
movies TV shows and games and has worked
on 11 different projects in 2019 alone I
instantly recognize his voice as the
legendary devran K from Destiny to
welcome back this time I did make to you
for you but I seem to have drunk it all
that character was one cool mother
father
Gideon also picked up the role of Fergus
Reid in the recent Wolfenstein games and
even played a character named after
himself Gideon in Call of Duty advanced
warfare man now I want a character named
after me in the Call of Duty series one
day I could even meet Kevin Spacey hmm
maybe not anyway Gideon does more than
just voice work and you may have seen
him pop up in films like takers the
recent daredevil Netflix show and you've
guessed it I don't believe I'm gonna say
this again he was in Teen Wolf the TV
series seriously what is going on Square
Enix stop taking your cast from Teen
Wolf
apex of apex predators right how about
someone who hasn't appeared in that show
then here's Erath
the character who told at our
heartstrings back in 1997
she'll be voiced by Breanna white are
you okay here
this is for you I am Erath
in the new Final Fantasy 7 remake video
game Breanna is one of the freshest
faces in the cast having only appeared
in a handful of major productions in her
young career after a few years holding
her craft in various short films Breanna
broke through into mainstream TV and
film roles a few years ago appearing in
shows like Criminal Minds and the
hilarious movie popstar never stop never
stopping alongside the Lonely Island
eras vocal counterpart looks to have a
long career ahead of her let's remember
this moment I was so happy I cried
another voice which instantly stood out
to me when I was playing Final Fantasy 7
remake is a wedge despite being a fairly
minor character in the grand scheme of
things wedge is voiced by one of the
remakes most established actors they may
not think you're a true believer but you
know what I think that interested I just
did it and then I went home and I was
like who knows what'll happen it was on
AMC's show but one of Matt's
breakthrough roles was also arguably his
biggest to this day playing badger in
Breaking Bad
one of the most critically acclaimed TV
shows of all time and I still haven't
watched it hey where you going he
reprised his role a chef to take on one
of the biggest parts in El Camino
Netflix Breaking Bad spin-off movie
outside of his run-ins with Walton Jesse
Matt has been getting plenty of other
work under his belt including some
pretty sizable roles in films like
Blackburn red-state and the animated
movie home for as impressive as his body
of work is there is one strange note at
first glance you'd be forgiven for
thinking matt had never lent his voice
to a videogame before but he has back in
2011 he popped up alongside the likes of
John Goodman in its software's
first-person shooter rage he plays a
minor character named
aybe who just sits in one spot all day
kind of like me interesting stuff
another character Final Fantasy fans
have been introduced to is Jessie she's
full-on flirty in this world and will be
voiced by erica lynn beck is he one of
us now he's got balls this what was his
name again I apparently sound great when
I'm screaming because for about a year I
books every single battle chatter
audition I ever did an actress who was
already built up a rock-solid body for
stuff a rock-solid body of work despite
only really starting up a few years ago
she lends her voice to many animated TV
shows and boy is she busy Erica managed
to notch up 22 different roles last year
alone Wow a great deal of her work is
anime focused she's popped up in loads
but one title I've not tried to say out
loud yet I'll try it now she's in Maggie
a record puella player major Maggie a
record well a Maggie Madoka Magica
player Madoka Magica
side story I butchered that so badly I'm
so sorry right now well that might have
been more than a little bit nice she
also played a huge role in insomniacs
recent spider-man game on the ps4
she plays Black Cats yes I gotta play
harder
I'm sure I've dreamt about her at some
point anyway moving on she also plays
lead character Miriam in blood-stained
ritual of the night and Cassie cage in
Mortal Kombat 11 no matter what type of
games or shows you're into there's a
pretty high chance you've heard her
voice somewhere so there we have it a
quick and hopefully helpful introduction
to the voice actors in the Final Fantasy
7 remake did you hear any other voices
or faces you recognize please let me
know in the comments below and I'll be
sure to make a follow-up episode also do
that like and subscribe thing it really
helps anyway it's been a pleasure I'm
Adam from Playstation grenade I'll see
you next time
[Music]